[Music]
hey Dwight Stanley one way or another
you are gonna come with me to make this
sale buzz hey can you just let me out of
here before whatever comes next don't
worry it's just a bull tranquilizer
nothing to be alarmed about it's just a
man pointing a bull tranquilizer at a
co-worker
Dwight you do not learn do you
for threat to be credible yeah oh no you
didn't do yes all right Andy approved it
man he's really in twinkle town now is
he gonna be okay
I mean weren't those darts intended for
an animal like two to three times larger
than him okay this dosage was meant for
a very small ball and Stanley's got way
more body fat than they do you give him
three shots Shh
got about 45 minutes to get him to the
client before he comes to grab his feet
let's go move it one two three like a
manatee ready let's go again come on we
can do this one two three Oh God
no wonder my elevator cables are under
such strain we gotta hit a wheelbarrow
or something yes
[Music]
we're good okay let's go push I am the
big weekend plans I might see a movie
nice what about you yeah let's go right
to the top of the stairs okay and then
what okay listen I'm kind of embarrassed
to admit this but I've never actually
done this before well if I may you're a
natural
thank you she may never hurt him I had
like a thousand times but it's a little
weird I know
Evel Knievel that's about as good as
that's gonna be okay now here's the plan
I'm gonna launch him I need you to go
down to the bottom and catch him pitch
yeah I can't catch him he's like 250
pounds use your hands and just blunt his
descent okay he's gonna be moving slowly
it's only 1 it's 15 feet down it's at a
45-degree angle get set in your haunches
like you're catching a medicine the size
of my life is okay good call you would
have put a hole in your chest same as
they put a hole in that wall we should
probably call the doctor
[Music]
you